genius brain listeners it is time
pre-orders are officially open for the
genius brain secret society
collaboration piece that was inspired by
my Japan trip you can expect the quality
and attention to detail of secret
society in every piece we do not play
and we still don't play with the
collaboration piece with genius brain I
hope yall really do enjoy this and
pre-orders only last for 2 weeks so cop
it while you can get it at secret
society that's s c r t s o c Ty y.com
pre-orders are for 2 weeks and then it's
gone forever so get it in while you can
s c RT s o c IE T
y.com genius brain listeners this
podcast is brought to you by better help
my friends you know I've been talking
about better help for the longest time
and I ain't going to stop because they
have been such a long sponsor of ours
because I currently use them still till
this day listen therapy is amazing it's
been great for me and I know a lot of
you out there think that I don't know
it's weird there's a weird stigma behind
it but listen if you're focused on your
physical health like I said you got to
focus on your mental health first you
know for me therapy can be a bright spot
amid all the stress and change something
to look forward to and make you feel
grounded and to give you the tools to
manage everything that's going on
because man the world that we live in is
tough and sometimes we need a little
help so find your bright spot this
season with better help visit
betterhelp.com genius today and get 10%
off your first month that's betterhelp
hp.com gen
my lovely genius brain farts that
podcast he's brought to you by
nordvpn listen nor VPN we've used them
all the time and let me tell you
something when I'm online I don't play
baby I don't let people go into my
information like that and guess what our
personal information online is super
important because there's a lot of cyber
security threats out there so what are
you doing don't play you wouldn't let
somebody come into your house and do
random things and poop poop poop po po
po poop in your toilet so you don't want
to do that online people are pooping on
your your online toilet use
nordvpn it is a must it is not something
that no maybe I should use no no no use
it all the time even if you're just web
browsing on YouTube so exclusive grab
the nordvpn deal go to nordvpn.com
genius and get extra subscription time
try it risk-free now with a 30-day money
back guarantee thanks to nor VPN for
sponsoring our show genius brain farts
this podcast is brought to you by mood
what is mood my friends mood is known
for their federally legal THC but now
they adding their most potent product
yet to the lineup we are talking about
hemp based thca flow the future of legal
THC so try it along with all of mood's
other amazing offerings like Delta a
flower gummies Vapes cartridges and more
I love their products it's super good my
friends you are missing out try mood's
new thca flour today and for 20% off
your first order and a free gram of thca
flour go to Hello mood.com and use promo
code genius that's
hello.com promo code genius for 20% off
your order and a free gram of thca flour
today what's up y'all I'm uzuhan you're
about to watch my music video Bona
petitte it's a banger I put a lot of
love and energy into it I hope you enjoy
it and uh thank you so much for the love
you shown for lover boy and I'll see you
on the
podcast I
love stop playing with me I got to cut
off the leash
do I up onake stop playing with me I got
to cut out the leash doging
me I leled up on a sneake [__] stop
playing with me I got to cut out the
leash doging
me I leveled up on a [__] stop playing
with me I got to cut off the leash dog
and me
going I leveled up by the sneak you
don't work harder than me stuck to the
vision I cut with Precision now none of
you Chon are touching my Ste
I just mind do my low dance I mind have
my new pants used to be broke chased out
the money now I get the checks in
advance I feel like I wasn't n now my
life sweeter than cin don't like a wi I
need 10 of them baby girl I feeling Roy
like T of them life has become like a
cinon when they see me in the flashh I'm
Larger than Life I've been working in
the background fit blacked out busy
moving and silence I leveled up on a
sneake [__] stop playing with me I got
to cut out the leash dog and me going
b i leveled up on a sneake [__] stop
playing with me I gotta cut off the
leash dog and me
going in five four 3 two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
The Genius brain podcast I am your host
David So if you're a first time listener
don't expect anything at all because I
have nothing planned or prepared but we
have a very special guest today we have
James H do you want me to introduce you
as your as your rapper name or your real
name do the rapper name
okayu first of all what what does that
mean okay so before I used to go by a
rapper named jhan and I wanted to change
my name cuz I just wanted like a brand
new brand new start so I was like man
all the cool names are taken like Kanye
West Drake they're all taken I think
Kanye is just his actual name I know I
know you might have to go back in time
and talk to your parents about that [__]
oh bro so I basically I was like uh let
me go to Google Translate and see what I
find so I was like typing in you know
the typical words I was like what's the
Korean word for hand
or what's the Korean word for you know
the best and then I was just going
through the Rolodex and I was like man
all these Korean words suck I typed in
excellence and then out popped uan so
like do you know that word no I've never
heard of that so like in Korean school
um there used to be like a Uzu hung a
Uzu award that I would always never get
so I remembered that and I asked my mom
I was like what does Uzu mean she's like
it just it's mean you're really good
wait so you went to like a legit hungo
then oh like in elementary school on
like a Saturday oh yeah y'all didn't
have that here no well we had Korean
school but it was forced upon me because
it was just it was like right before
church started so the church would do it
and so my parents would [__] beat my
ass and they would take me to Korean
school so I would do that in the morning
then I would eat like six donuts and
then I would do Bible study and then we
would do worship and then we would have
activities after so it was a whole
[__] thing like we Su on Sundays to I
dude my dad was a uh was one of the the
[__] what do you call it we were
Presbyterians so he was one of the
[__] people the the uh uh ERS yeah so
he's like one of the elders and then he
became a pastor so I had to go when he
went which is at the butt crack of Jesus
wasn't awake then dude and I had to
[__] show up so early I remember
going to that church being the first one
there and the last person to leave and
all these people would look at me like
what are you doing here it's like d my
dad is still working here so I'm just
waiting around while everybody goes home
bro yeah praise God I love it yeah
praise the Lord yeah all right so if you
guys don't know this man was based out
in Atlanta and you said you just moved
now you're permanently here you made the
you made the big move which a lot of
people don't do Rel relatively so yeah
like I I'm still trying to see where I
want to land but I'm spending a lot of
time in LA okay so you're so but you are
going to move here though right that is
the intention yeah well it's holding you
back though why why won't you I think
I'm just looking for certain
opportunities or um that [__] doesn't
come that way dude yeah it never it
never works out that way like everybody
does this conversation thing before they
move to the city right number one I'm
not saying that Los Angeles is a place
for that everybody has to be in right
like everything is so Global everything
is on the internet nobody technically
has to move here right or to New York or
some of these bigger metropolitan cities
the only purpose for moving here is for
you to feel like you're in a creative
space and there's other people here that
could help grow that right yeah that's
the biggest thing that Los Angeles or
these bigger cities have to offer when
you kind of live in a smaller town
everybody's yeah everybody's happy doing
their own thing and they kind of have
the the white picket fence the house and
the kids which is beautiful but when
you're an artist you kind of need to
feel like this monkey on your back like
there's somebody coming after you or you
need to get to a point where all this is
worth something when everybody else is
satisfied around you you become
complacent too that's why I can't move
back home even though I love my hometown
Sacramento but when I'm there I'm a
little too complacent like everything is
kind of too good when you're here you
feel that pressure of wanting to be
better damn that's that's a very good
analysis my God damn I mean that's why
like look I have other friends too shout
out to my uh buddy Josh uh this [__]
still hasn't moved from Atlanta to here
I [__] been telling this dude for
like six seven years and when he started
it was when he first came here he came
in and out obviously for different
opportunities but what happens is like
Atlanta also is a hot bed for a lot of
culture right right but there's but
there's this little thing missing and I
don't know what it is in Atlanta you
know I mean there's something a little
missing film went over to Atlanta right
but there's not a lot of big things
popping out there and it's just enough
to keep people there but for some reason
when artists go from that place to Los
Angeles something happens whether it's
because of the pressure of wanting to be
better or other people just kind of
boost your creativity that move becomes
something that allows you to grow
exponentially I don't know what it is
though I mean being I've been in Atlanta
for like eight years so I only have my
theory my personal opinions you know I
it's a great place if you're black to
receive that kind of support and
infrastructure and I don't know
emotional support yeah yeah yeah you
know uh and I have a lot of friends in
the industry who do music and film you
know like connecting with with them is
very for them connection is very easy
but like I'll just go from my advantage
point like when I meet people I'll pop
out at an event and I'll be like hey I'm
an artist and they're like oh that's
cool get out of here Asian boy get the
[__] out of here as much as like you
know cuz a I see a lot of media come out
LA and be like oh my God like the like
the needle has really been moved so much
and I'm like yeah to a certain degree I
think so but for people like me when I'm
out in different you know not LA or not
California I meet people and they're
just like oh that's cool it's novel but
it's not enough for like and I'll be
like yo I I'll hire you I have money to
pay you let's work and collaborate but
sometimes it's not enough like Social
Capital it's there's not enough like I
don't know there has to be something
outside of just the money for you know
the people that I've met yeah I don't
know what it is the people who do want
to work with me are usually like
probably like you know watch a lot of
anime man I mean look is that like
frustrating for you as an artist do you
feel sometimes like hey this is where my
greatness is and then people just aren't
seeing it yeah bro I mean I think I
definitely have those frustrations and
in one sense I'm grateful I went through
those frustrations because I feel like I
have a perspective that a lot of artists
and value creators don't have cuz you
know for some people 1+ 1 equals two you
know for me 1 plus 1 has never equal two
it's been like10 for I'll give you
another example I was in Nashville um
for this like uh music event and I was
talking to this uh can I say white boy
is that is that I don't give a [__] he's
Italian
he has a spaghetti it's a different hey
hey respect you
know I was talking to I was talking to
these producers you know and music
people uh you know of white boy
producers yeah okay and they're very
talented and and they were just asking
me about my story they're like yo you've
been doing music for a little bit like
tell me about what you've learned and
what kind of sound you want to make
moving forward so I was like hey I'm
interested in like you know like house
and UK garage you know and like all
these things that I'm in the future want
to make or like I'm currently I do
melodic rap blah blah blah I tell them I
shifted into that world because I used
to just be kind of like rap and I
realized just doing only rap with my
face and my Suburban background doesn't
it just doesn't sell like when you when
you think about the Rubik's Cube that
you got to create to to make the right
product to sell some [__] like I I
didn't have the right Rubik's Cube and
I've been trying to shift it around and
I was trying to explain to him you know
like I just think maybe like R&B I sell
it a little better or or maybe if I was
in fashion I'd sell it better you know
like this face or if I'm a doctor you
know I'm just trying to get him to
understand like like do you understand
I'm trying to say it without saying it
yeah you know and then he was like you
know but like Kanye you know he was like
he decided not to rap about drugs and
not about the streets and look at where
he went and I was
like he's black yeah you
mean yeah yeah and he was like oh I like
I swear I I scared him away I was like
he was like oh I think I can get some
drinks why like why do I have to explain
it to you 1+ 1 equals 10 for you man you
know all you have to do is talk to Mommy
and Daddy and you might know somebody in
Nashville connect you which is great
like use what you got but when I try to
explain my story it just doesn't read or
it doesn't land on some people who just
didn't have to deal with it which is
fine like I don't I don't use it as a
crutch I use as like yeah you know my
thing for this is like this like
I've it's it's hard to kind of carve
your space out in a world full of clones
right everybody is a clone of everybody
else now right and this is not to
conflate the idea that we all gain
inspiration from people right but
adaptation has even died now now it's
just what do you do I'mma do it make a
carbon copy of it and I'll take some of
your clout and fame and then I'll just
be somewhat successful with that and
then everybody follows this whole you
know train in this genre right I thought
about doing that I was like man maybe I
should just cuz when was hot in like
2016 I was like maybe I should just copy
Migos like Cadence wise everything and
you know what people would probably have
been like damn he's fresh yeah 100% you
know because different Avatar yeah you
know but I mean I I would say this
though right everything for me in my
case let's say for I'll use myself as an
example right there are so many
different things that I've I could have
done in my path to make myself way more
successful than I am now right my level
of success is what I enjoy and I I
literally was just having a conversation
with this with my wife yesterday and
it's very seldom that me and my wife
actually have heart to Hearts right cuz
I I [__] around all the time like she
wants to have a heart like I got in
trouble the other day because she wanted
to talk about having kids right but I
was too tired and it was really hard for
her to bring it up and she goes she goes
hey I really something serious to talk
about it's like girl I am tired as hell
you want to talk to me about this [__]
and I and I knocked out but she wanted
she she was like trying to buer up the
courage to talk to me about this [__] so
I kind of [__] up so we don't have
like these heart to Hearts a lot right
so we were talking about this where I
was telling her you know my my path and
my
career has always been the idea of doing
the things the way that I want to do it
right and if I don't have that then I
would have never been in this space and
how I look at it is this if it was
always something for just like financial
gain right I could have just worked a
[__] job you know like that that path
is a lot easier right I could focus on
what I need to do get that money walk
away and then do other things but the
but the objective of the things that I
do was always to just do things that
kind of made me happy right no matter
what the result is now I can't going
down that path is very hard why because
the the the likelihood of you being
successful in that path versus just
copying what other people do it's a very
very slow burn slow bur right so a lot
of the things that the well that you're
going to have to constantly go back to
is is go back to your mission statement
it's like why am I doing this in the
first place as long as you stick to that
all the other stuff doesn't really
bother you so much right when I see
other people who are successful doing
what they do I'm just like oh that's
their path this is my path and you're
going to have to just anchor down on
that mostly and I'm not sure if this is
for you but I feel like I I've had this
conversation with other people a lot of
that honestly kind of comes with like a
an idea that you don't you probably
don't believe in yourself as much as you
think you do right because there are so
many outside factors that come to you
that tells you that you're not worth it
yeah you know and it [__] your head up
a lot it [__] it up a lot and it
happens to me too when I started going
into acting and I would go into these
rooms and I would see these other people
and I'm like I know I'm better than you
and I'm not saying that the flex but
garbage is garbage and I can see that
[__] floa in the water you know what I
mean and so I'm like oh I'm better and
they would take these roles from me yeah
I don't know what it is right but I
don't dwell on that maybe they were the
better person in the room I can't take
away from them but I just have to know
that I'm good with myself so when I
leave these auditions I don't ever leave
disappointed because I didn't get the
role I leave happy because I did the RO
the best that I could you know what I
mean and those are the things that keep
me afloat for you in your case when you
go go into like this music industry
first of all there are a few things that
I believe that are very very difficult
in entertainment it's not acting it's
not even writing and directing I think
those are very difficult jobs I think
music is one of the hardest things right
it's so ever changing and evolving all
the time you have a fan one day and the
next day they [__] hate you right and
that might be true in any type of
entertainment case but with music you
have that one Banger album how many
times have we seen somebody come out and
they're just a one hit [__] wonder
and that is a lot lot of artists'
biggest fear it's like after I drop this
project on the next one are they going
to remember me are they going to care
about me do I need to change my sound do
I need to evolve or what if I like the
way that I am and I want to keep it but
the next album no nothing sells well
money is power right if I have more
money this goes into this whole [__]
thing you know I mean it becomes very
[__] stressful for
you like in your case what I see is that
you are very good at what you do you're
very excellent at it I think from what I
seen in this industry you might need a
little bit of [__] excuse my French
you need to be a little retardation you
know I mean you need to go full-blown
rward you know what I'm saying wait
unpack that what what does that mean re
so I know what the damn word is oh my
God
yeah oh my
God I'm sorry what and look I'm saying
this in in a good
way because some of the most just
disconnected [__] human beings
believe in themselves so much it's
unreal even when their product is trash
and I there's people I follow on
Instagram I don't even know them but
they just popped up on my feed and I see
the hard R in their
eyes and then I use them as motivation
for myself cuz I'm like they're garbage
they could do it if they could do this
every day they wake up they get their
Nokia flip phone and somehow they upload
this video on Instagram this potato ass
footage and they're out there they put
on that Justin Timberlake song and you
see them just [__] dancing you know
what I mean and they upload it cuz they
think that they're [__] dope and
guess what it's not one video it's like
a hundred of them yeah and every day
they believe that something's going to
come of this even though it's not you
need some of that hard R hard R in your
life is great not the not the n-word one
but the the other one the the hard R
like the hard yeah yeah yeah do it
together I know the hard R in your eyes
dude dude I'm Gary ve I'm Gary veing it
right now I'm about to get cancelled but
you guys I'm like on a serious
note I have seen some actors too who are
trash right but they go into every
audition everything that they do as if
they are the [__] and they
book they book I don't get I'm not doing
their auditions right they're doing
commercial auditions or whatever but I
follow them just to see what they're
going to book look I had this guy he was
doing an audition right I for I don't
even know what the role was for but
you're not supposed to post your
auditions before anything happens he
goes in right oh he does he sends his
audition and then he uploads the [__]
before he even sends his audition which
you're not supposed to do he clearly
signs an NDA psychopath and in this
[__] video he's doing a role for like
a homeless person but he has like half
his dick out and he uploads it on
Instagram and I'm like dude the power of
the hard R dude he book it yeah he books
it oh my God how I don't know but that's
the type of confidence that a lot of
people need some of the best actors and
directors when you meet them in person
they're [__] nuts they are so out of
it I truly believe even though most
people don't think I'm normal I think
I'm a little too normal for Hollywood I
could see that I know what you're saying
you know what I'm saying yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah what I want yeah I I feel that
way too I feel like I'm a little too
normal I was telling your team you know
I was like I just want like a Suburban
House house you know plot a land I want
to see my dog walk you know run around I
want kids but see this is what I'm
saying you can't you can't have those
thoughts you have to have the thought of
I want to buy a rocket ship you know I
mean yeah see that's the kind of that
that's funny you you do need that kind
of crazy man you do need that wait let
me ask you this yeah what do your
parents think about your career I'm
always curious about that because nobody
wants their asan baby to be a [__]
rapper yeah you know what I'm saying
yeah yeah yeah man should I do it in the
most honorific way of our parent or no
just say whatever how you feel I shout
out my dad all the time dude yeah okay
well no so I love my parents they
they've supported me by you know giving
me a Suburban upbringing MH when I
started doing my music stuff in like
2010 I was still in school so they're
like it's cute you know you do you study
for stuff on flights you know study for
exams it's cute once I graduated I got a
job as a graphic designer and they're
like oh good he's on a career path but I
still was doing shows going on tours and
stuff like that and then once I quit
that job and I just started only doing
music they're like you know you should
like consider real estate you know you
should consider uh being like a news
anchor or like they would just always
news anchor I don't know the randomest
[__] ever they know they don't know
anything you know about like the job
opportunities and what kind of Lifestyle
how come you don't want to be a
president of the United States yeah
exactly it's like you they're like they
just kept like uh like slipping little
things in you know to tell me like hey
do something that's a little more steady
yeah you know and I mean there's this
one one story where like you know I was
uh I don't remember what year it was but
I I was at Panero with my mom and uh
like we saw some like old church people
or some people that went to our church
and they're like oh James you know we
haven't seen you in forever what are you
up to you know blah blah blah um we
haven't seen you in forever and then my
mom was asking them about their daughter
and um I I was like Mom why why didn't
you tell her about like you know the
music stuff going on and blah blah blah
and she was like she just didn't really
answer she was like come on yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah hey come on hey man
you're you're you're a special you're a
rward don't do this you are you're a big
rward you know that exactly you know so
I mean obviously she loves me just kind
of like you know if you tell people he's
an artist yeah they they probably think
he's like a
dumbass or all the things that they
assume you know related to that so you
know for the most part my my parents
they try to support you know like they
they'll like listen to my music here and
there you know I have a day job too I
work at it and it's remote that's how I
could like afford to do most stuff
nowadays yeah so because of that you
know they're like happy about it but
they're like you know there Comes A Time
in a man's life when he must take
responsibility like I agree with that
statement but I don't agree what you're
saying dad were your parents ever the
type to like yell get mad nah n they
never really yelled at me like that for
reals cuz I I disappointed them from a
very long from a very early age me too
but they still yell at me they still
yelling dude they still dude my mom
every time I come to the door her fist
is like this it's like I didn't even do
anything yet like what you what are you
mad about just in
case you know she always has like one
cocked ready to go she like [__] dude
my mom always yells all the [__] time
I think my parents are
toxic like my parents don't yell at me
really yeah have they ever whooped your
[__] ass yes they I got whooped a lot
when's the last time you got whooped
years ago what do you mean oh yeah me
too yo wow yeah last week damn that's
crazy yeah me too man it's been a while
yeah so you don't what's the like you
remember the age it was like high school
bro High School yeah oh my god dude get
the [__] out of this podcast no wonder
nobody believes in your [__] Street
Credit I got you didn't go through
enough man dude my dad used to [__] me
up dude you would have thought you would
have thought he was my pimp and I didn't
give him my money like I didn't he would
beat the [__] out of me dude my dad once
threw a office chair at my head I was
like eight all right that's crazy yeah
dude my dad was [__] violent and he
was a pastor too yeah that's so wild in
the name of the Lord bow oh my god did
you ever have to do the stuff where you
had to hold your hands up yeah yeah I
did a lot of those classic punishments
oh okay thank God yeah so I'm very
familiar yeah my God I yeah dude I my
parents they they worked at the cleaners
though all the time so they were I think
they were mentally too drained to like
really like go at me of course like my
dad's yelled at me and stuff but it's
cuz like I did something wrong it wasn't
like abusive oh you're so lucky dude I
am fortunate I mean my dad was a pastor
he ran a business had to take care of my
grandparents but he had always an extra
[__] you know a couple gases in the
tank is smack me up a bit dude bro what
they use like their hands or everything
dude it was like when I walked into the
house and I knew I [__] up I would try
to hide every object that they could
[__] [__] me up with yeah yeah yeah so
like one time genius brain listeners
this podcast is brought to you by better
help have I told you guys that mental
health is mental wealth well with better
help you can get on track for that
therapy has been pretty awesome for me
and I know a lot of people who have used
therapy now and that stigma is slowly
starting to go away that um therapy is
for somebody who's weak that you don't
really need it well I got to tell you
guys something man get on it this time
of the year can be a lot it it's to feel
some sadness or anxiety about it but
adding something new and positive to
your life can counteract some of these
feelings therapy can be a bright spot
amid all the stress and change and
something to look forward to make you
feel grounded and to give you the tools
to manage everything that's going on I
love it I've been using for a long time
and that's why they've been a longtime
sponsor so if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and studed to your
schedule all you have to do is fill out
a brief questionnaire to get matched
with the license therapist and switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge so find your bright spot this
season with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com genius today to get 10%
off your first month that's betterhelp
hp.com genius my lovely genius brain
farts this podcast is brought to you by
Zach doc when I need to look for a
doctor that works for me I definitely
use Zach do if you're not on that you
must be stressing out Zach do is amazing
let me just give you a scenario okay
have you ever been on the hunt for a new
doctor and you asked literally everyone
for a recommendation you know a doctor
who actually gets you and finally after
weeks of searching you find the one but
uh-oh you call their office you have an
appointment available but
then doctor doesn't take your Assurance
well wipe those tears away put away the
ice cream and head over to Sock talk to
find and book the Doctor Who is right
for you and I'm going to tell you
something right now saves me a lot of
time and raise your hand if this sounds
like you you Obsession follow that super
credible health expert quote unquote on
Tik Tok if if that's you don't do it you
listen to all these Health obsessed
folks but they don't know didly Squad
are they actually a good doctor there
are thousands of top rated doctors on
Zach do though they're all listed with
verified patient reviews so you can find
a book The Doctor Who not only has years
of experience an actual medical degree
but also gets you and here's the thing
guys Zach do is a free app it's free
where you can find all these amazing
doctors once again it's free my friends
so get on it what are you waiting for go
to Zach do.com genius and download the
Zach do app for free and find book a top
rated doctor today that's zocdoc.com
genius zach.com
genius genius brain farts this podcast
is brought to you by nordvpn look if
you're snoop snoop snooping online H
guess what you better be using nordvpn
everybody can see your stuff if you
wouldn't let people just open the doors
to your house come in poop in your
toilet eat all your food and the trash
your place why would you do that online
your online home is important because
all your information is out there so you
need need a
VPN even if you're I don't know on
Netflix or you're just streaming stuff
online you got to use a VPN and let me
tell you something nordvpn is the best
it's the one that I use if you're online
you're doing anything you need to
protect yourself and do that with
nordvpn I am not playing you should not
be playing because cyber security
threats are happening all the time so
protect yourself once again with nordvpn
so exclusive exclusive exclusive grab
the nordvpn deal go to nordvpn.com
geniusbrain and get extra subscription
time try it risk-free now with a 30-day
money back guarantee once again
exclusive deal go to nordvpn.com
geniusbrain and get extra subscription
time try it RIS fre now with a third day
money back guarantee thanks to North VPN
for sponsoring our show I remember my
mom well this is actually my let me tell
you this Grandma story so my grandma
used to whoop my ass with this thing it
was it's like a Green Bamboo stick that
you use to steak plants I only know that
now cuz I do tomatoes but but years ago
I didn't know what it was for oh the
thing with like a tip it no it's just
like a green bamboo stick it's bright
green oh it's like a deep green it's
like this color green okay okay and so
she used to whoop my ass with that to no
extent my grandma did everybody was
whooping my ass dude I never got a break
mom would whoop my ass and they were
like a WWE Tac and would come in just
and then I would go to my grandma's
house and then she would whoop my ass
too oh my God so she had this green
little bamboo stick one day when she was
whooping me it [__] snapped I never
experienced that type of Joy ever again
I recently just got married doesn't even
[__] match up to that moment dude
when that wooden stick snapped I
remember going thank God and this woman
goes to the back of the couch apparently
comes in packs of 24 oh she reup so in
like 6 years she never had a reup so she
brought I remember the bag that she
brought out from the back of the couch
it was Dusty as [__] and the logo on it
it said 24 count it was blue and yellow
oh my god oh it's a multicolor it's and
then she whipped it out that bamboo
stick if anybody knows about it that
[__] was so fast because it was light it
was aerodynamic so you couldn't see it
but you could hear it so it would just
be like you would just run and you just
that's a crazy switch D this woman would
whoop my [__] ass my parents actually
at a certain point um I mean this is
kind of sad kind of funny me now sad in
in in reality so she used to like whoop
my ass so bad that but she never whooped
my brother's ass right so I just didn't
know why he's younger he's my older
brother what yeah my well my older
brother's very calm right he's a nurse
he's very very kind very sweet dude and
so I would just laugh at everything but
my grandma hated noise so I would just
crack the [__] up as Sunday cartoons and
she hated me laughing for some reason
children laughing kills her soul like I
don't know the CEST thing in this world
I know she [__] hated it though if
there was joy in the house she wanted to
take it out and so she [__] I don't
forgot what the [__] I did but then she
hit me but she missed my my my butt or
my back cuz I was running and then she
hit me in the eye right here and then my
whole face welted up well my dad saw
that and then he I didn't know this
until I got older but my brother told my
dad that Hony was beating me up too much
and then my dad was like what are you
talking about so he the the [__]
wealth on my eye and then I didn't see
my grandma for like 3 or 4 years or
something like that I don't remember
this like I I literally don't remember
God she got banished she got banished to
the shadow realm they were like never
again I literally don't remember this
though I only I I remember the the
hitting on the face but I don't remember
the Gap where I didn't see my
grandparents damn yeah but then that
happened because of the ass whoop but my
parents they didn't know how to like
deal with their emotions you know what
I'm saying my dad had a rough upbringing
my mom grew up [__] Farm por and [__]
yeah we were struggling with bills and
as a young person or as an adult now I
can see why they were just so angry like
I was a [__] psychopath as a kid
right I was one of them sticky kids you
know I mean you know that one kid in
class that for some reason is always
sticky even though I drink water and
then some I had like clammy hands yes
clammy and just sticky all the time I
was one of them like gross ass kids yeah
yeah yeah moist so she didn't know how
to deal with me so they would just whoop
my ass but they also didn't know I have
like like severe ADHD didn't exist when
we were kids right you were you were
just a kid who chose not to pay
attention that was just always
rambunctious and in trouble but the
things that I Excell that were like
sports it's because you're always moving
around all the [__] time so like for
them they didn't understand so like when
I used to get whooped all the time for
me it's like some of my best memories
like I I don't know why I don't know why
but I [__] look back and I'm like
yeah I remember I used to get my ass
whooped and I loved
it you don't you don't relate huh no no
no I don't look back on it and like damn
I laugh about it but I'm not like yeah I
like that what was the worst weapon you
got uh my dad uh he moved from a uh he
used a remote and then I think it wasn't
inflicting enough damage so he got a
piñata stick that he found from like a
old uh what's the pinata stick made out
of it's just
plastic it's nothing CRA your life is
great dude bro I'm you know dude my my
dad once I think he [__] he gave me
one of those Spartan kicks you know when
they kick him down the well right in the
gut I think it's cuz I was like farting
too much it just like I was stinking up
the whole [__] living room yeah he
just got cuz he's trying to eat dinner
yeah and then you know your boy over
here just [__] blast him off you know
and he's like what are you doing I'm
like I'm farting you know why would get
mad at me for farting like yeah that's
natural it's it's so smell so bad but I
can't control it because at the time I
didn't know I was lactose right and I I
had a [__] ice cream so I just kept
farting I remember he just got sick of
it he just went B a kicked me in my gut
and I farted again cuz he hit me in my
stomach and it made even more mad oh my
god dude my parents were [__] wild
dude yeah damn I guess I don't relate in
in that sense that's a good thing though
I'm glad you had such a great upbringing
you piece of [__] like yeah man look
it's what keeps me grounded I guess but
at least like you know for your parents
at least they have a a better tact to
like speak to you right they kind of
they kind of just subtly but they don't
know how to deal with emotions like I I
I relate to that you know like when
like I I express some sort of like
sadness or you know especially like what
happened to past year for me like if I
express any sort of negative emotion
it's really hard for her to be
like oh did she would she just come up
to you and be like you she'll just be
like no she'll be like it's okay it's
like I didn't ask you if it's okay I'm
just telling you how I feel you know and
I'm like why am I having to explain this
to you wait your so I want that's so
interesting because I feel like even
with my parents I can express emotion to
them you know what I mean and then we
could actually have that because we're
very extreme like there's no peace in my
house right it's either like extreme joy
or Extreme Rage there's no there's no in
between you know so if I tell her about
my feelings she'll do two options she'll
either console me or she'll call me a
gay boy but like but one of those
options I I they actually they express
themselves though yeah you know what I
mean yeah they're not my parents I would
say they're more of the just just don't
express it brush it under a rug like I
remember one time uh I like my dad he he
was like feeling remorse about like one
of his businesses that he had to close
down like back in the day I'm sorry yeah
that's so funny you know it's it's it
was sad for him you know like this is
like you're telling him your feelings he
goes shut up he goes why are you sad to
my
business but like his son's feelings
don't [__] matter yeah no no it it
wasn't like yeah it was it was basically
like him expressing himself and as he
was crying like my mom yeah yeah my dad
was was like sobbing and then my my uh
mom kind of got up and like went to get
coffee and never came back and I yeah
kind of and then I and then my sister
kind of like walked and like got some
napkins and then I found myself like
leaving the table to like get like
something like a fork you know yeah
you're like Dad and it's Bas is awkward
dude yeah I realized like at the time
it's like oh we don't know how to deal
with emotions especially I mean even for
me I realized like especially like the
guys in my life not only my family but
friends
when I see like dudes expressing
themselves or especially the internet
bro it's [__] online well that's
different the internet they express
themselves too much some of them need to
just shut the [__] up yeah yeah yeah I
do yeah I do agree but I don't know man
like I I've realized like expressing
emotions is is like a difficult thing I
didn't grow up expressing ourselves
everything was just suppressed so it was
just you could you did you express a lot
of Happiness though on the other hand or
you just like with your father was
something good like if I if you won the
lottery you'd be like it is time and
that's it did you just walk away uh
they've gotten a little more expressive
over the years but it like we we didn't
have like we weren't we never went on
vacation you know like we would just
like celebrate with food and we' be like
M this is great and then I'm known I I'm
like a very joyful bright person but in
my family everyone knows me to be the
sensitive emotional one so I don't know
what that means you know like you see me
right now and I'm like smiling all the
time I love being Smiley and happy you
you know I enjoy that damn your parents
are robots dude kind of in some ways you
know but I've noticed now like as my dad
gets older he's a little
less dude they get so sensitive now yeah
yeah like he was listening to like the
uh new songs from my album and he was
like he started like crying cuz he was
like I can hear the things that you went
through
really and he started tearing up two
tears yeah I was like and then I like
cuz I was driving and I was like I saw
from the my peripheral and I was
like if I see my dad cry man I I I lose
it I'm just like I'm driving like this
you guys are crashing your car a bunch
stereotypes yeah bro it was yeah yeah
yeah so it's it's changed a little bit
but for the most part I'm still I feel
like I I'm trying to learn how to like
express myself and and express my needs
and I feel like you do that through
through through your music though a lot
of people are kind of like that I do
yeah yeah yeah I've learned to do it
through that a lot of people are more
expressive on like this cuz it's almost
like when you have an artistic arm
you're it's like a different person yeah
James Han and uzoh Han are two separate
people so the way that you express
yourself as this artist is going to be
different than how you do it in your own
life it's true and sometimes and I say
this with the young people right how
many times have you see young people man
they talk that [__] online like crazy
and you meet them in person little
[__] it's like you're a little [__]
like you would never say that to
somebody in person right cuz like it's
easier to create that Alter Ego than for
you to just you know put that into your
own life well and it's also helpful like
you want to suspend reality to like
process something you know you need to
sometimes in order to like understand
something about yourself you need a a
playground to like maybe explore that
idea I mean you do that in movies you
suspend reality for the sake of some
idea you want to explore yeah you I
think for me like the extension of
myself to this thing is still
essentially the same [__] person if
anything I might be a worst person in
real
life like you know like I've never been
able to really deal with um living a
life of Duality like it's too stressful
I can't do it it's it's almost [__]
physically impossible for me I could do
it to the sense of in a social group I
can I have a lot of nuni right so I'll
look around and see like okay maybe
being myself might not be the best idea
like if I go out to dinner with my
wife's like co-workers I'm not going to
be like hey did you see yeah did you see
this down syndrome Tik Tok you know show
them you know yo are you on cringe talk
I can't watch cringe stuff because it
physically hurts me oh oh you get the uh
what is it secondhand cringe yeah it h
it physically I Okay so Tim always sends
me cringey stuff cuz he knows I can't
watch it there was this video of this
guy in a theater right and this kid he
he's the classic brace face with the
long hair or whatever greasy looking kid
you look into his room roaches
everywhere disgusting and he's like hey
guys today and he's not doing this as a
joke this is him doing a daily Vlog and
he's he went to like a premiere of some
type of Star Wars thing or whatever and
before the movie starts he goes well
today I just wanted to get the crowd
going he goes who's ready for the movie
and then there's one person going yeah
and he sits down he goes I felt good cuz
I got the crowd going and just watching
that [__] felt like a thousand knives in
my ey just like [__] God damn it stop
it I wanted to grab him and Shake him
like just do the screen just don't do
this you're better than this yeah but
then I can't watch cringe stuff just
kills me man I just you know what if I
look back it just reminds me of of like
a younger version of myself right where
you just did so much embarrassing things
cuz you wanted to impress people cringy
back so when you're a young person
that's you're just this cringy little
character but you know why cringe talk
is interesting I I I have this one take
on it it's just like as as a person who
enjoys the social sciences I think it's
fascinating that these kind of humans
exist oh I I I very much enjoy it but
like enjoy the fact that those people
exist yeah but just it hurts me to watch
for sure it's painful it's painful I'm
like this the whole time like there's
like levels to the cringe too I'm just
like like like yeah it's just the whole
time it gets pretty [__] bad man and
like I said those cringe people though
watch they're going to be the next
biggest rapper out there cuz they
believe in themselves so much they got
the hard R man they got they got the
hard R in their hearts dude yeah so I'm
telling you like when I see that stuff
it just makes me feel H I don't know man
cuz I just don't know how long they went
throughout their whole lives this way
and then nobody said anything yeah you
know but then again it's like when I
look at that it's like like they're
happy so I'm like maybe maybe this
person has it right maybe they got it
right maybe I'm the one that's wrong
here yeah you know what I'm saying I
think about that sometimes yeah yeah
because when I see other people enjoy
themselves is it's not the way that I
want to enjoy it it just I'm like maybe
they have something going on it's like
that have you ever seen that one video
like the uh protector of the basic have
you seen that YouTube video that it's
like a old video me me and uh Sam we
talk about that video all the time it's
this video of uh I don't know it's like
some hipster girl it's like back in like
early 2000 hipster girl is like talking
to this girl who's like oh I love my
pumpkin spice latte and she's like G
you're so basic and then all of a sudden
this fairy dude pops up and he's like
I'm the defender of the basic you know
how why why are you uh uh like hating on
her she enjoys her life you know if she
likes to eat vanilla ice cream let her
eat vanilla ice cream she loves her life
you know why you got to be so down on
her just because you hate your life true
I mean look I I feel
like the people in the world who kind
kind of live like what most people call
the basic life or typically like the
happiest because it's ignorance is bliss
you you don't need much to be happy
right and everybody towards like the
later end of their lives they always go
back to basic I mean that's very telling
cuz you you've always seen it how many
times you know these [__] celeb when
they get older man when I was younger I
was doing all the stuff that I thought
would fulfill me but now I realized all
I wanted was a peaceful life everybody
says that same [__] story every time
right and
it says something about life right like
I just don't think we need that much to
be happy everybody tries to like fill
age this void that's just impossible to
fill with you know what we'll we'll
break it down to like physical Beauty
right I don't know how many times I've
seen it somebody's [__] up face just
walk around as if it's like the most
normal thing ever and as they get older
they kind of hold on to this thing youth
because that's how they value themselves
right I'm that person that's valued by
the way that I look so I need to keep
this as long as possible and you you get
the they all look like [__] cats you
know what I'm saying and their face
looks so insane and look like I said it
goes back to if that makes you happy but
it's never been the case from what I've
seen you know we I've lived in the city
now for 12 13 years and I've seen the
people who try to hold on to their youth
the towards as they get older they start
doing the crazy diets they're crying
because they're getting older here they
try to fix something else it becomes
fixed for a second they read a comment
about them getting older and they freak
the [__] out it's like [__] you're
supposed to get old yeah you're embrace
it man Embrace that [__] you what I'm
saying I mean I say you know keep your
beauty as long as you can but it's not
supposed to be forever dude it's just
the most pointless thing it's the most
pointless thing to invest in like I say
like why why I just still don't
understand if I went back right and I
looked at my mom genius brain farts this
podcast is brought to you by haris thank
you for sponsoring this podcast thank
you all for watching and listening so we
get to continue to be supported so
support Harry's and let me tell you
something I love Harry's before they
even contacted me you guys already know
I've been using haries that's how I say
smooth like a dolphin baby but not only
that they have legendary high quality
razors and skin products like
exfoliating face wash and Hydrating
Lotion Harry's gives you a premium shave
without the premium price tag and guess
what you can get better quality and a
better price than other razors when you
get haries delivered right to your door
and let me talk about the convenience my
friends look razors are something that
we always use whether you're a guy girl
whatever you are if you want to stay
smooth you got to get on that Harry's
baby the starter set is a $13 value for
just $3 at harry's.com genius it
includes a five blade German engineered
razor weighted handle foaming shave gel
and a travel cover I mean that's a
pretty amazing deal if you ask me so get
your best shave ever with Harry's razors
and skincare products get a $13 starter
set for just $3 at harry's.com genius
that's harry's.com genius word $3
starter set today my lovely genius brain
farts this podcast is brought to you by
move mood mood is known for their
ferally legal THC but now they're adding
their most potent product get to the
lineup we are talking about TCA flow the
future of legal THC tried along with all
of mood's dope offerings like delta8
flower gummies Vape cartridges and a
whole bunch more and for a limited time
mood is giving our listeners a free gram
of thca flour and 20% off your first
order just visit hello.com and use our
code genius now what do I use my mood
products for for me it helps me sleep it
helps me relax helps me feel less achy
less sore calm all of that stuff so I
actually use some of the products before
I Spar um when I when I kickbox or box
it just helps me get into a better mind
State and of course uh with the sleep
stuff you guys know I've had uh trouble
sleeping my whole life so guess what
this stuff helps me out I enjoy it a lot
uh try mood's new thca flour today and
for 20% off your first order and a free
gram of thca flour go to hood.com and
use promo code genius that's hello M
o.com promo code genius for 20% off your
order and a free gram of thca flour
today and then she got a face lift and
[__] I would [__] cry cuz it's not
the face that I know yeah you know what
I'm saying it would literally kill me to
see my mom feel that she's not worthy
enough so she had to do something to her
face to make her feel like she's going
to be loved and I would [__] hate
that like even for me now the the woman
that I married one of the biggest uh
things that I wanted in a partner was
that they weren't really on soci social
media because it [__] up the personal
relationship so much from all the noise
that she'll hear about especially like
your platform and my platform other
people's stuff and she's not really on
the platform that much she just does
whatever yeah um so for her she keeps
her sanity but she her sense of self
isn't based on what other people say
right right and like for me no matter
what if I wasn't with her the another
person that I would be with is somebody
who doesn't who isn't on social media
yeah I just I require that that right
because I have to be in this because of
my career choice right it's it would be
stupid not to so it's just I don't know
man like you you you're going to move
into this city and I I feel like as long
as you have a strong foundation and a
good group group of people around you
you'll be perfectly fine but sometimes
like those thoughts those evil thoughts
will creep in yeah cuz life is always
about comparison like you just can't
help it yeah somebody who's you'll see
somebody who's another artist that's in
this your same lane and then I don't
know something might happen to them yeah
and it makes you feel a certain way
about yourself which is a very evil
thought to have but it always Creeps in
somehow you know what I'm saying um
really random just cuz I'm looking at
your shirt that's the that's your brand
right oh yeah so this is well so I do um
what the [__] I move the mic away from
my face I'm G to podcast you idiot
but this is this is um uh my collab that
I did with with my uh clothing brand
secret society yeah secret society yeah
so we did a pre-order for this this was
one of the most difficult shirts I've
ever [__] made in my life like it was
impossible to get this down right that's
why we're not making that puffer print
it's puff print and then the back it's
the oh boy yeah uhhuh so that [__] was
damn near impossible to [__] that DTG
does that director AR no it's
not huh yeah this is not DTG so that's
why it was [__] hard to make oh man
so we did multiple batches on it the
first batch all [__] up because you
have to keep the screen on there
perfectly aligned every time and it's
like [__] 20 layers
yeah so so that's a screen print on the
back a screen y'all are insane at least
how many colors it's a lot it was like
20 colors or some [__] that's ridiculous
it was ridiculous to make that's maxing
out the whole so there was most people
who didn't want to make it for us cuz it
was just so much [__] work and plus
this shirt cost so much to make you
didn't make much profit off of it but I
wanted a little drop shoulder to it I
appreciate it yeah so all of our stuff
too like you know when we did this when
we did secret society it's just it's
also like one of those passion projects
yeah yeah I could have put this on a
cheaper body but you know we we do all
of our stuff as cut and so even the
shirt is this is our body you won't get
this anywhere else yeah yeah I didn't
know it was a c So Dope so we do all of
our own bodies so yeah obviously if we
make this shirt and we sell it if we got
a a blank which blanks are fine too it
would be a lot cheaper I could profit
more but I didn't like the way it fit so
it is what it is you know so we try to
sell it at a price point where we could
take some money from it but it wasn't a
lot it was so [__] little but I just
wanted to make this [__] shirt so a
lot of people got it so it makes me
happy when I see people walking around
with it because it was inspired by my
trip to Korea oh well you ate so good
man oh dude I I gain like what like 10
pounds in what two weeks that's that's
nice I eat I eat like literally the
apocalypse is coming tomorrow it's it's
it's actually disgusting like sometimes
when I eat and I you know if I'm sitting
somewhere and then I see my reflection
like in the in the in the like the
[__] glass I get a little disgusted
yeah like this dude I would order food
when I was in Korea and they're like is
anybody else coming I like two more
people yeah I like no no no this is just
for me and my wife dude it's so easy to
eat bro and all the it's just Superior
in Korea yo dude the Korean food in
Korea is so Superior good dude dude it's
so good I thought the cbop for a long
time I thought like the uh what What's
the big one hbat or chin uh chinor CB
yeah yeah yeah but like all those spots
in La I I thought they were very good
and then I just go to some random spot
some Aima where she has like a like a b
like a pig head just in the open you
walk in it smells like [__] because you
pass by all the you know dead animals
dead animals sit in the back bro that
was like the best cookb I ever had yeah
like Korea's food well there was that
that clip of uh Ben Baller where he was
saying that the the Korean food in La is
way vastly better than the stuff in
Korea and I was Ben Baller Ben Baller
you mean Ben Baller yeah huh yeah so he
why he say that cuz he's a [__] idiot
he's a [__] full-blown idiot yo
Korea's Korea super
well I you know he been man that well to
his credit I would say that he's older
right so he's like probably almost in
his 50s so I know during the time when
Korea was going through a lot of [__]
our food was better here because we had
better quality ingredients oh okay but
it's different now so maybe I I don't
know the OG yeah I I don't I didn't even
know that context yeah so back in the
day like around when we were younger so
let's see when I was I would say you
know third grade so 8 years old eight
eight or eight or seven years old around
there yeah 7 what what back then we used
to send stuff to Korea all the time so
like the medication the the vitamins and
stuff all came from like China and it
wasn't very like reputable so they would
always ask us to bring vitamins to Korea
and ship it to them because they
couldn't get it right and so when you
would go to Korea too uh the food wasn't
as great because the quality of meat
wasn't good and all this other stuff
well now the the import and the export
in Korea is fantastic crazy so the food
there is [__] amazing and you got to
understand too for other people like
Korean food is all they do in Korea
Korea Korean food is just
food dude have you had Italian food in
Korea yeah I'm not a big fan of that
might insult you I'm sorry but you know
yeah [__] he just we got an Italian
man he just whipped out his salami he
was about to hit you with his salom he
was but like Italian fusionar yeah
Italian Fusion is good you know but I'm
not a big fan of Korean Italian Fusion
pasta for some it doesn't hit me I like
Japanese Italian Fus oh that's very good
but for some reason Korean Italian
didn't hit that I had this one spot in
shinchon it was random it's just I
didn't expect anything to be good like
like any American food to be good yeah
and I'm always impressed by how like
well it's not American food but Western
food how they like remix it I'm like
damn one of the things that Korea does
really bad though for like like a disra
definitely that that's oh I forgot about
that fud's not good also a pizza yeah
it's not good or it is good it's not
good because I don't really go for p oh
yeah yeah yeah the kuma pizza and stuff
yeah I mean I think those things like
creatively taste good right but if they
try to do like they're scared of char
cuz they could like Korean people equate
Char with cancer right immediately they
do they do so when they put it in the
oven it's the pizza's always [__]
undercooked yeah it's because they don't
want the Char but that's the flavor so
it's [__] always I had pizza like
four times in Korea it was same same
every different place they always
undercooked it because they don't want
it to be charred so it's like but you
need that like what the [__] are you
doing piss me off but then you go to
Japan and they have their Japanese
neapolitan pizza [__] wild dude it's
so [__] good with their food yeah
they like Japan's food experience was
crazy for me like when I went there and
I ate the food yeah similar to Italy
right they really care about their
ingredients being fresh 100 sometimes
dude I just want to like do a whole
YouTube page of me [__] up Italian
food just because the ingredients are
trash cuz the reaction would be visceral
dude when I see Italian people freak out
about food it makes me die laughing it's
so [__] crazy how particular they are
about their cult which I respect a lot
but you do a like a car like carbonara
right the moment you put a drop of cream
in it just one Italian grandmother has a
heart attack in you know she just flip
flips the [__] out starts flipping
Tomatoes like she gets so upset there's
a guy that I watch his name is
Vincenzo's plate shout out to Vincenzo's
plate I know you don't know me but when
he reacts to other people making Italian
food I I love it dude why what why you
do that what is this you put a you don't
need
a supposed to be here and then you see
him freak the [__] out it [__] I love it
dude cuz it makes him so mad sometimes I
just want to send him videos of me just
[__] up all of his food you know I
mean making a shitty little tiramisu put
only chocolate powder no espresso and
just send it over say it's better than
any [__] Italian food I've ever had
but respect right I like I like that
they enjoy their food that much but you
know once it gets into the hands of
another culture it's going to get
changed yeah happens to Korean food
Japanese food or whatever as long as it
tastes good I'm okay how do you feel
about Fusion Foods most Fusion Foods I
think T don't taste good because most
people don't know how to fuse it but
then a lot of dishes now are already
Fusion right Vietnamese food is Fusion
that's French influence oh with the bun
with the bunm the even F people kind of
say it's like a con or something like
that right depending on where you get
the F right uh Korean food has a lot of
American influence we [__] love fried
chicken that's American GI cheese yeah
we love mozzarella cheese in Korea goes
wild now that's crazy and we're all
lactose yeah I don't understand there's
cheese everywhere in Korea all the like
we love fried chicken that's American
adaptation so sure black G came in
they're like hey you see this [__] and
then Korean guy was like oh what's what
the [__] man you know thank you very
much they took that [__] you know very M
yeah and they they made that we you know
America 2 is all Fusion food I think
like the the the concept of fusion is
when you take two cultures and you just
kind of put things together I don't like
it like big respects to Roy Choy and his
kogi truck I hated Ki truck I did not
[__] like it at all I thought it was
just it was tortilla and you put Pugi
inside it and I'm like this is not
really Fusion you're just smashing
things together yeah yeah yeah it didn't
feel like they were like doing a dance
together no disrespect to Roy Choy by
the way I think he's like The Godfather
he really kind of put like paved way
yeah for like Korean people like
especially in the food scene he put us
on the map I really appreciate but when
I had K I wasn't a big fan of it not to
say that I can't respect what he does
didn't you um did you ever go to cgo
back when he had uh yes that's his right
that was his the one in Chinatown yes I
loved Cho really I did not like it yeah
why I just it just didn't taste that
good it was just it was just very this
yeah well not being from La I didn't
have the same I was just like damn this
is a cool food I heard best friend in
Vegas is good though I heard great
things about that place so I can't wait
to try that but um yeah you know I think
Roy's just one of those guys that he's
he was an innovator so like you'll
always get my respect for that but you
know for for my taste by the way if you
had the food and you liked it that means
you liked it like it doesn't mean
anything just my preference but I had um
there's a lot of people that were doing
food at the time that I got really
disappointed in like um Eddie Hong had
his bow house his b New York yeah yeah
they had one in La yeah he had a couple
I think I did not like it at all yeah
yeah it was I was not it was a Cool vibe
you walked in and you hear like you know
'90s rap I don't give a [__] about vibe
I go to a restaurant for [__] food
dude honestly um somebody in La I forget
who it was uh uh he does videos uh but
he put out a video where he was like you
know when I go to a restaurant and I see
like 3.5 Stars that's the place I want
to go to because they probably focus on
the food don't give a [__] about like
the vibe and they put it all in the
product when I when I look at reviews
right and the first thing somebody says
they go these people were rude I'm like
next what's the next one see next review
the food was amazing but the weight just
cool I'll probably go here cuz like for
service wise if you treat me like [__]
but the food was Immaculate I'll let it
go you know what I mean just give me my
food right don't steal my money just
give me my food but if you came in and
you were just like I don't know like any
typical Asian restaurant hey what you
want yeah right great and then she she
sticks her full ass thumb into my soup
and then serves it to me hey like a good
time dude as long as it's [__]
delicious I Yelp reviews too they always
talk about their feelings and I hate it
like just tell me if you like the food
or not dude I don't need to know why you
woke up today and then your [__]
husband left you and then it's just when
I see a review it's this [__] long
it's like dog you have no friends you
were the Biggest Loser I've ever met in
my life if I see you I'mma kick you in
your summon like my dad did that's right
bow too much a fight oh my
go what what are we at right now uh 58
minutes 58 minutes you got time for
another one yeah all right we'll we'll
do a little bit more on the music side
the the [__] podcast got away from us
I was supposed to asking more questions
but sometimes you just have your friends
in here and you just [__] [__] no
it's cool bro but anyways guys this
wraps up this episode of The Genius
sprid podcast uh all your socials line
it up and then also the new video that's
going to be dropping
soon you line it up [__] oh what do you
mean what does that mean put talk your
[__] okay okay oh my bad I thought it
was like gonna be done okay so follow me
on uan music on all platforms um I have
a new music video coming out Lover Boy
uh it's for my new single that came out
it's going to be a great music video uh
I hope you enjoy it it's going to be a
great time next podcast we're going to
actually talk about his
music we'll see you all next time genius
PR every Sunday's at 12:00 p.m. secret
society SE TS o c IE T y.com our first
line just launched this year because of
all these complications a lot of the
stuff is kind of out but we will be
doing a reup real soon hopefully uh and
then we also have a genius brain collab
piece coming out uh Black Friday on
November is going to be inspired by my
Japan trip it's going to be [__] sick
uh genius BR every Sunday at 1200 p.m.
we'll see you all next time peace genius
brain farts this podcast is brought to
you by Harry's look you guys know I
always use Harry products when I shave
and that's how I stay so smooth and sexy
my friends in fact somebody once told me
that after I used Harry's products I
look like a sweet sweet pumpkin and I
was like why thank you hey a smooth
shave going to be rough on your wallet
the the starter set is a $13 value for
just $3 at harry.com genius so get your
best shave ever with Harry's risers and
skincare products get a $13 starter set
for just $3 at harris.com genius that's
harry.com genius for a $3 starter set
today